tu as entendu parler des questions cons
et oui on en a parlé oui je sais qu'il
peut arrêter d été élu oui j'imagine
qu'un jour le pen fasse 51 % aux
élections qui viennent présent la
république
oui tu préfères ça où tu préfères qui
est plus d'élection pendant dix ans pour
éviter que ça arrive et est bien vrai
dire je n'ai pas d'opinion toute façon
je ne vote pas qu'est ce qui te gêne le
plus d'acheter minutes des capotes
anglaises miniature pourquoi non parce
que c'est ça qu'il faut répondre non je
sais pas je capote tâche est souvent
n'ont jamais t'as pas peur avec ce qui
se passe en ce moment non pas bon non
c'était très fidèle et romario si oui
avant ça pour ça et qu'est ce qui te
dégoûte le moins l'homosexualité ou le
voyeurisme qui me dégoûte rémois temps
qu'est ce qui te dégoûte le moins loin
oui si tu devais pratiquer un de ces
deux sports lequel te dégoûte le moins
l'homosexualité ou le voyeurisme
aucun des deux groupes rien ne se
dégoûte j'ai des trucs qui te dégoûte
quand même oh oui sûrement
qu'est-ce qui le dégoûte le moins la
scatophilie ou la nécrophilie à un
environnement légal
les deux démarches et oui oui dont la
première fois c'est aucun et puis la
deuxième fois ci les deux voilà si tu
devais être incarné tu préfères être
incarnée en marguerite duras soit en
marilyn monroe marine bowie layton comme
en france et oui imagine que lui hier
matin toute la radio tu apprends pl la
bombe atomique va tomber dans cinq
minutes
qu'est ce tu fais dans les cinq
dernières minutes qui te reste à vivre
tu t'en vois pas en l'air avec ton mari
en cinq minutes